things look bleak for Tony Stark and the
Avengers and game trailer but I am man
has been in some pretty tight squeezes
before and the game's cast includes
spacefarers gods Wizards interstellar
warlords and more in all likelihood
Starks rescue isn't a question of Earth
but of who and when Tony spends the
Avengers and game trailer leaving a
final message per his one true love
Pepper Potts so it's only fitting that
it will probably be pepper who saves him
not only would it be an emotionally
satisfying payoff it also makes sense
pepper was talking to Tony when he left
Earth so she knows where to start the
search as the CEO of Stark Industries
she has the resources to mount a rescue
and as Tony's fiancee she certainly has
the motive plus we've seen her rescue
him before in Iron Man 3 perhaps the
biggest clue though is the fact that
leaks from the set of Avengers endgame
suggested that Pepper would be donning
her own suit of armor for the film
that's some of the things she's done in
the comics where superhero code name is
rescue just the record being interesting
space for Cheryl promises rescue us more
funny sounds yeah it seems pretty
obvious when we put it that way when
Thanos snapped his fingers and caused
the decimation the only two warriors on
distant Titan left alive with Tony Stark
and the nebula it's unclear whether
nebula is on the ship of Tony in the end
game trailer but it wouldn't make sense
if she ended up saving Tony after all
she has plenty of experience flying
these super advanced spacecraft plus she
may be able to use her status as a
cyborg to help repair the ship we know
she will want revenge on Thanos for the
death of Gamora and saving Tony may just
help her get it after the heartbreaking
loss of Groot at the ends of Avengers
infinity war rocket was essentially left
alone on earth it would make sense if he
left to find out the fate of the rest of
his guardians of the galaxy family
unfortunately they were all snapped out
of existence back on Titan but if rocket
goes searching for them he could very
well find Tony instead Thorin Tony are
best friends but they are both founding
Avengers and the odeon CERN isn't going
to leave stark hanging if he can help it
thanks to his new hammer Stormbreaker
Thor seems to be able to access the
Bifrost and teleport vast distances
across space if he goes looking for
Stark perhaps with the help of his new
sidekick rocket
Stormbreaker could help him get there in
the nick of time tony isn't the only
refugees set adrift in space due to the
evil of Thanos
there's also half of the Asgardians who
are attacked at the end of thor ragnarok
endgame director Joe Russo has said that
Valkyrie survived the attack and funds
certainly hope that scene-stealing
favorite Korg also survived it would be
fitting and thrilling if Valkyrie and
Korg showed up in the nick of time to
rescue Tony after Wang saved tony from
certain death in Avengers infinity war
the two became instant best birds so can
one do it again in infinity war dr.
strange seems pretty nervous about
Starks ability to get them back to earth
implying that he couldn't do it with
magic but why not if wizards can step
between dimensions
why not between planets sure they need
to visualize their destination but if
Tony is able to get a video SOS back to
earth
maybe one can open a portal with a sling
ring and get them both back to the
church in time Captain Marvel was
nowhere to be seen in the Avengers and
game trailer but thanks to the Avengers
Infinity Ward post-credits teaser we
know should be an important part of
endgame and we know from the Captain
Marvel trailer that she can saw through
the spaceways under her own power what
better way to introduce her to the
Avengers and by having her save Tony
Stark things look pretty dire for Tony
in the end game trailer the things have
looked pretty bad for him before and
he's managed to work miracles with far
less so it would be no surprise if
Tony's suddenly got a flash of
brilliance that allowed him to save
himself after losing everything in the
fight against Thanos it seems as though
his confidence is at an all-time low but
maybe his love for pepper will be enough
to shake him out of his stupor so he can
fix the spaceship and get home in one
piece
the shockingly bleak end of Avengers
infinity war had many fans and tears but
what if Marvel saved the worst blow for
last maybe what we see in this trailer
is exactly what we're going to get Tony
alone in space drifting off into
oblivion never to be seen again
would it be disappointing yes
devastating sure but is it likely well
probably not but after the way they
cured off poor Peter Parker but you
wouldn't put anything past those
monsters